hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to an update
video 4.0 since I'm kind of starting a
new here
however you wanted to find that but yeah
welcome to update video 4.0 let's just
get right into this guys so as you all
know or at least I hope you all know
this channel was actually suspended from
YouTube for two long weeks and all the
videos were down a few people noticed
instantly because of Twitter and then it
kind of spread and people realized that
my channel was suspended and it was
wrongly suspended I contacted YouTube
I got everything back and I'm really
happy to say that all my videos are back
all my subscribers are still here still
watching my videos and it means a lot to
me that you guys are still watching so
first of all thank you for that it means
a lot to me guys the second thing I want
to get into is um I really am NOT going
to be applying for a partnership again
not maybe not till I have maybe ten
thousand subscribers
I can do without a banner really for
much longer it's not really my goal here
on YouTube but I want to do the whole
reason I'm making these videos which are
tutorials not unboxings and reviews is
to help people some people can watch the
video and know what they need to know
about the product that's the point of
these videos so the fact that they're
back up on YouTube means a lot to me
obviously and I mean a partnership isn't
going to do much except allow me to have
an awesome banner and upload more than
10-minute videos so I guess I'll just do
the whole part 1 part 2 thing for the
intro tutorial and all that so I'm not
gonna be applying for that for a very
long time the third thing I want to say
is um the new YouTube mega widescreen
which is actually actually getting to be
annoyingly wide now do you guys really
want me to produce my videos in that
1920 by 960 which I'm realizing is a 2
to 1 aspect ratio I don't know it's just
it just seems really really wide and um
the way the YouTube works is if you
upload a video that is not the full
widescreen the YouTube player with the
play/pause and the HQ and all that at
the bottom won't fill up the whole
YouTube wide screen so it kind of makes
your video look like it's fitting but
it's really not anyway
you guys wanted to see you want to see
me guys stretch the video just a little
bit to make it fit the YouTube wide
screen or just leave it in 1280 by 720
16 by 9 so that's the main question of
this video and I want you guys to answer
that last but not least as the school
year moves on I'm going to be balancing
a varsity sport a couple of AP classes
as well as this YouTube channel and it's
the time is really limited for me to
make film script and edit these videos
so I'm thinking there's going to be a
mix of between 3 to 5 videos per week
which is still a lot I know a lot of you
guys don't get to log on to YouTube that
often but it's gonna be 3 to 5 videos
per week you're not be it's - just gonna
be it so that's the frequency I'm gonna
aim to upload my videos I'm gonna spend
a lot of time with them obviously I'm
gonna be editing them I'm going to be
writing the strip's I'm going to be
making sure everything is good and easy
to understand so that's why it'll takes
a lot to make a video last but not least
I was thinking of making a video or a
video series of ken your Mac do this
sort of series of videos now I don't
know if it was gonna be too
controversial or if he's gonna get in
the way of my tutorials but let me let
me know what you guys think of that but
first of all what do you think and
you've been a YouTube mega widescreen
because that's my first priority with
making videos but yeah ken your Mac
could do this kind of tutorial for your
your PC users out there I know I know a
lot of my users are Mac OS 10 users but
I might as well give it a shot right in
summation I will be applying for YouTube
partnership at a very long time time in
the future maybe 10,000 subscribers this
is up a four-point-oh thinking of using
the new YouTube make a widescreen not
sure yet and making a Ken your Mac do
this video playlist or spreading it out
during the upload of my videos anyway
thanks for watching this update video
and thank you for watching all of my
videos of course and I hope you continue
to rate comment and subscribe and um
just help me out spreading the word
about my products and the reviews that I
do so thank you very much for watching
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
video peace
you